yes hello and welcome to this video
this is something in german so everyone who
could only understand english is now
guessing what i say yes we are doing documents here
this time but in german so what's it
called then double chattering blitz or
elvis guth longer going on what is that
at all a pairing for this so the
name of the black player yes logging is
not so relevant for the time being actually
because that is only a test of the
chamber as the colleague has probable
games actually had
another moment not a bit
complicated in any case also has
one  channel on youtube and also links
it so we'll both comment on
it you have to say that my opponent has the
channel has that would be a
rating between 1900 and 2000 but
he also has a friend who
is probably also a gm so around
23 to  24 euros what
should help me a bit that this is not
so bad mismatch on sunday people has
to  i still say we
are already playing the second game here we have
already played one before that was
actually the first game of this
recording session and what happened was pretty
stupid we had a total
draw position and yes there was actually
nothing going on and i still had  10
15 seconds on the clock we
now play 10 minutes and 5 seconds element
and then put it at the door of
course I didn't know what it was
if then if then went to see
it could have been more important
it was just that I have to  say
completely stupid inquiries from
a neighbor who then asked me where I then
from whom I then for a time this game
and also the whole dialogue with the
neighbor it is completely
pointless we played a game before that
was really very and
exciting and we  we then
decided
that was there now
somehow yeah that was just stupid to have to cut the
chain name wolf because
it has to now  t don’t care what
the neighbor asked with stupid in
any case we’ve thrown it
away
now we’re doing it again so we’re only
going to play two games that’s the question here are
variants in so that I can play this
somewhat boring variant with
four chess back then  because I simply don't
know anything better
it's not bad so white has a
good chance of a
small advantage here the knight
also has c6 also not so good
black now usually
plays bishop 6 in this first game then it
was stopped by the neighbor
control has to be  recognizing that it's
a very normal girl
personally group and balanced that
was there actually really didn't know anything at all
in the pawn earlier
but no serious chances of winning it
was just total remy really
stupid i didn't have that
much time then and then  told is what we
do
well what does he play black is actually  ch
runner your sex yes well d5 pending is
still tied up on c3 but actually
completely 46 hkd a6 to fc 1 runner the
six on how something like that now
always comes a6 when the top people play
this here
then you actually do it because I do it
white
bishop the six and then the queen comes
back to d 1 and white tries to
jump to a4 knight to 25
plays on the queenside acts like one has a
slight advantage
maybe that's the case but black
can't be in a bad position
really doesn't have any  bad pieces in the
sense
that it takes a bit more bishops the
six knights after ii 7 and
so invest a bit of time to
sort
things out but with the two runs and so
black should actually be okay
I have a bit of a problem with
this variant  i don't think that
the complicated things are of a
ragout from somehow also bring much
so little then mostly this
pragmatic solution with the  drama four
chess i have actually good
results here if i had that so more if you look at
it here the new one in
tournament chess i had drago are
so long ago that it wasn't so
i'll put it as a print i mean you can
do three too  play first there are yes
these particles are with white against
subscribe vowels won very
nicely i think that was part of the six
game series from the carlsen continue the
goal 2015 could drive me crazy but i
mean that was so yes jumper here 70
joke played at some point at least
this time
something special is going on here
i'm just wondering accessing this
episode is so completely kosher
but something like here is probably not one of
the company
the 5 if he takes jumper takes e4
with it jumper draws the six but it
is now  I don't think anything
earth-shattering is what I'm wondering if
I just pulled the 1 with it,
the derby 3 then looks very, very, very
stupid  I'll do that I'll do
that and in the park the thing on 25 thom the
eighth is now very obvious and
also springer c5 that's of
course that's also possible of course,
but I'm always really
unsure whether that's somehow good because
now of course you weaken very often
hang
do three don't think
about it too long now so it's difficult
for black now how do you want to do it
here the a6 always hangs so the rook
on 8 can't easily
move if you play a  5 pulls you have
weakened the entire gut wing so you stand, for example,
a springer c35 trend similar 10 10 5
p 6 p 5 also makes a terrible impression on the
c5 totally weak i'm not
sure if that's so great for
black but has to  you say that
as long as the six is of course this runne
is of course damn diffi
ult to wi
something somehow, i.e. to win mater
al a  On the 7 yes that is of course a
brutal move but there is often
no unusual idea
almunia also played it back then the
tills not now necessarily in this
position around the position
I don’t think was achieved but in terms of the idea it was
an interesting idea  is here moved how
so are two with the idea springer i5
weindorfer e5 de find
so that 7 is possible the question for
me is do i do b4 here first or
not i do that sometimes makes it sometimes
not quite clear if i need it but
it is  also a question of 10 minutes
and 5 seconds isn't
really 4's now that you can just about
classify under rapid chess but
it's also very close to blitz and
then to take very long time-outs if
we're not sure behind the
ongoing world cup die  first
quick games are 25 minutes and 10
seconds and then i mean the next one
is 10 + 5 and if you look at it that way
it's s  ehr bizarre
lightning-like less rapid than lightning
so there's a yes the ag 4 or
maybe
you want g14 well I really can't
say how I'm supposed to play
that draws two and then
threatens to jump five
he makes the halm
that wasn't right now  too long ago
generally we're going to do
some actros operations here,
pretty much something like runner
r5 then i'll do runner the three but not
fully satisfied with if now
after exchange
because from the structure the
position is now good for anyway  cry c7
is weak c6 weak somehow so
I don't have to think about it too much now
yes that's that of course it's
very hard but alright I thought
jumping 50 would be really good now but of
course he has f4
that's natural then it was coming
I should have found out directly that I should have played differently
would have achieved a lot
jumps there comes f4 it's not so clear
what I then play in  in fact I
should maybe
play three first g3 fgf knight e5 something like that,
yes, black can maybe really do it a
few times because by taking on 4
5 I probably supported that a bit
with the f5 thought good knight fulfilled
is quite nice  but that's
not so great out at all
let's think about it here what is then can I
do something else here what about the spanish
c5 of course I have
n't seen it before but maybe it's very
interesting like cbc and the bishop is
caught
interesting knight  25 like
cbc no one knows anymore what that is
4 that's not bad i think i
don't think i'll do what do i
do here now
if it doesn't work bad luck
and of course i didn't plan at all
beforehand i actually thought okay
game jumper invented but he does
then 11 4 and then on the b5 it does
n't really help much either,
a point is of course if black
now moves the bishop e6 believe me  e
somehow not that that's good but he
does what I thought that
maybe then the three jumpers
are of course possible around the five hoops then
both jumps up like 5 through the
place that these jumpers that the a4 aren't
exactly great then up
once it gets really
good i guess black hooded
the abc bbc and then what i g4 or something like that
takes on the six takes on f3 also
takes in the 7 i have that should
actually be good
46 it doesn't work
what can you do it recognized bcc
somehow then the bishop has two
or something playing
that is a very
strange continuation but at least I break a piece of
the king's wing that's possible
so stupid that's a bit strange but at least
fathers of the pawn since bcp number 2 knight
has two and then r4 or something
that looks like a player after all, according to
bcb cb net, two takes the cd to
me and i'm counting on double
then not not very glorious
i don't think it's a  such a bad
idea or of
course you can also b- c- b- c- and
then just let it be taken yes like that r4 or
something like that then I can certainly take the
six and maybe somehow
then go on to 27 more
black every knight has r5 that is
not that great either yes I think the
black
one just has to be that was
right find the right one I'm not sure
what but so says runner has two
yes I didn't think it was
not good but good okay I'll take you  63
amg she commits not only it says white
would be if you win ok i have to
now i think or wait a minute if i
take the sixth cd he has
r4 right after that but i still
couldn't imagine that it's that great now
experienced jumper  the 30.34 or
not that you hit first then ask
what nope that also works with the matter
idiot that just courage
how stupid how stupid what an ingenious
amount of
performance I just have one figure less
no, I didn't do that at all,
I didn't see that at all,
that means I would have had to
import spring, that would have gone through,
say 10,
what should I have thought
about again, I just pulled too fast
,
well, you can't do
any tricks either  my plans
man oh man oh man oh man is
there anything else I can do
ok I have to take a look
a bit of a
four is coming well ok I'm not giving up
right away I'm trying to see
if I would still get the
Peasants' War or something like that on the six, for
example,
but when black really says
win you
don't have to  also my goal don't
give in to any illusions just roll de 8 and
then jump 6 is probably good
that's the crowning glory easy  the pawns
then hold
okay me good here i can
maybe try the b7 to get the ball
i mean he can always he can always
do something like him 14 and try
to win the whole attack and now i
thought maybe the 7s
somehow to the csi excuse
me a little bit of pressure
put less pressure on the clock a
bit on your nerves to the 11 7
there i might even actually have
50 is not that simple at all so if
i now take f4 here or what surfer
five moment is running  five i can also i
can do it or runner fulfilled
what happens then
knight law doesn't work he runs
seven tunisia also looks good or
what does another f3 or something never have
i go 3
or what comes you do considerable cup
doesn't matter  if it doesn't work it doesn't
matter
i deserve to
lose the game just do it here no
row just ask me that we could
still be a bit dangerous  so that
takes two with check and so
maybe I'll just take it again because
34 38 might be a move
I don't know exactly what I'll do then
maybe I'll just take a6 it's
a bit stupid after the six
so you'd really like to have it now
I don't think black or I
can mouse over them again of course
there's something here has a runner has 31 no that
's not so bad
you mustn't forget the physicum
and so in black now
lets you run very under long then I'm very
ready here for a round  with to
gamble 28 times only I watch 7 then
I have that I have six then
we just agreed on it I
mean he ok he wanted I go
play three so if he takes three now
maybe had somehow takes next to
it filled or something like that  could be
next to take so that g5 could be that of
course it's a shame that just so
takes lady takes the 45 of course hangs
e3 and port
the three d  Amen 50
that's really bad it's
really really easy you can't even be
careful
and when I'm with the fifth he once dame
half life 2 7
there's nothing in it either I
can maybe trick him a bit
that worked just fine  I still
think I really don't have a train
left mini 5 so something and
I really don't have anything else to play here
either
I don't know what's
the relatively best thing here now what's
here a little a bit and he's
tricking  once or so somehow
not only unfortunately nothing
about the black here
to confuse a bit fw33 all
so that the four go there comes is like so
flat probably come so that the 41
or something I have a better
service fails f-22 chess  king in the
corner lady f2 is broken,
unfortunately everyone thinks that too, unfortunately, that's empty, just
something else you can put back with it or something,
I can't somehow
d  corners absolutely not so only with
something that is totally stupid
go back with it or something that is of course
totally stupid at the moment space I have I
have that from the from the figure set
and insofar it is completely
okay that I lose
now you know where it is  the button here is
the button here can take revenge
so it does branch if i
have here i can equalize here in this
match how do i do it now best
rematch right here the rematch and
afterwards you can look at the style games there
like in the  first game that was
italian i can say oh
that was so boring
i have to win somehow here what
do i do now social
probably if you want to win so
yeah i'm playing at the moment i'm trying
here the camera led
let's see what comes up  this is played
here again in freestyle freestyle
moderately knows me
not really looking good
so how does it work now  here runs 7
and then at 5 or zone or immediately b5
that's it
I'll do 5 yes that comes first p5
p7 and then it runs believe me
that's right if not I ca
n't do anything
after that you have to set it yes
look a little more relaxed yes I just had to
have sprüngli 110 just
really didn't build it that
that didn't work
if someone was on g20 well I take it
away now and then
it only runs I think that or only
b4 we can  I can't admit
that anymore I've looked at it but
I can't get it
okay how firo blaspheme knight four
discs how stupid I'll do it
now jumped a4 or knight b6
sorry spider a4 or spree two
little clue players maybe
you could  imagine that springer b6
and such stories here
are
a topic no idea how to go there now
that's kind of a kind of theoretical
position but not quite me  I
think the i7 runner comes normally yes it can be
but it is so bad here maybe
springer 42 used later i
can't imagine
that it is such a problem for black
what you want he still has the move he comes of
course so what do i do now  the thing
doesn't open so easily on p6 what do i tell
g5 there is always a train where
i can take you to the port with that
thing probably i have to
look here because i sometimes
threaten things like 545 and the  seven is
somehow as good as you are somehow
sometimes a problem
maybe it's hard to run 6 m and
at least you have to make
sure that seven doesn't go
sprung p6 p8 and then he moves somewhere
after c4 or something like that doesn't make the fans
go it doesn't work
well  maybe just jumper b6 and
then he jumps with the idea then he
runs five to play enough because it doesn't
come actually makes
sense somehow but I have to go to b8  yeah
well like that now he's going back now threatens
bishop e5 if i play you six
you take f6 and about six away so
what's that now here is it
really stupid or what would be stupid my plays a
few normal moves and then it's
bad  yes often 5 of course
really a bit stupid
well I can do what we do in five
games but that's such a
strange one that turns out to be so strange
in this f1 b5 diagonal 1
ok but running is
a bit stupid  can you somehow
stand the six bishop f6
gf knight the six that somehow
bearable the position is not
really alive it doesn’t work at all
well we five do it but hamas looks a bit weird
there I can believe it’s my turn
especially since after g5 I really
the 5
okay comes afterwards but if that can't be disproved,
I don't think I see anything runners 5 each is
too stupid if it comes I'm
really really floored is of course
also stupid because you experiment a
bit with this opening knitted
the hardest possible variant in
front there is also enough stuff that is
totally harmless
the ag 5 are normal but who
knows what's going to happen here
very, very jokes here is when i
'm not quite sure  but if springer
i3 kemmer goes maybe in five years
to catch the bishop
he doesn't have that many
fields right now but not sure if that's good
he probably knows from the
book you can maybe even
do the strange 25 you just hit the ball
attack and the 59
the five are very logical should bring the
player to the edge
i have to go more or less after he
five
yes quite strange the position of
course not badly suited
to win somehow that's not
exactly boring but whether it's
objectively anything  I doubt it's good,
but
you have a feeling that something should go here that
really gets me
distress brings 55 just maybe
the five and on knight the six
or so good 5 I can
maybe also I can maybe that's
not that great anyway
I can also take g4 probably
I don't know exactly
maybe maybe but you can of
course 5  really come good
independent springer ag 54 springer the
sixfold is the problem
g7 hangs too of course also am very
slow long needed to understand op 5
that in the position is
actually probably
what we do to 7 with also publisher
measures five springer the four  springer
the 6 because it was there
doesn't look good for me it would
n't look good
can I maybe maybe I can play
with the a5 that could still be an
issue
so something like e5 player g4 g5
shouldn't be thought about for long either
me  I have to go here anyway I'm going to
go from g80 really too ill from
yes what's coming now maybe three something
that sees something gefä  Honestly,
now I can't see you next to me
, but it's pretty brutal
here, I can't take what's being done here,
really, not okay, let's see
, then, jumper f4, what's going to happen then,
often 545 with it 4 and then the six-
or it's yes  not so clear
but what comes on dame f4
i really don't get it what comes on b 4
in the position here
sorry i don't get it help what
comes then simply jumper f5 connection
or something he can't even do
the dame ten runner i3  or I
get it, I'll just go back to
27 and is that worse than that
, two or what could easily happen or will he
somehow attack them and
I can't play in six because
of that, of course, there can be more four
bishops e2 or  something like that
you can't play nige six was
the bishop on the four is that's
cool
lady four bishop e2 now really that
that's now that's the plan
jumps 5 is a serious impending i  ch
can also take the two and hour he
is 14 can that's also somehow
doesn't work either so that
means there's more 43 and what happens then
that happens when I just
go back to 27 comes then he runs
two or what then g6  should
actually work I'm too bad
doesn't understand it's just
getting away from me now I don't get it if sven sits
here somehow flat is the name of the
deserved
runner i3 I thought I'd go back
then the ok good beautiful one I
didn't see it of course of
course  kinda sun
what to think of it now
actually good i can
i can of course spit the quality here
with tommy 5 i probably even have to
do that
and do i have something else to do depends
yes because it doesn't depend on where else i can go
here or  can I
here lady there times four she looks too
fantastic what to
do what if I now how how
do I give the torment now  ity off with thome
5 or with dame d2 and then I ca
n't possibly go with a5
that's not as stupid as it looks
maybe well
already very average 26
terrible my pieces are really
bad bad
knight is particularly bad
I can do something somehow  I'll do five
queens he four knights four bishops you
5 somehow get that running
springer g6 then I'll take it away or
something welcome I'll do something like that
four springers f4 0-5 springer ag 6 so
and now well I could too  runner I think about it
four times
more it's not so hollow maybe
if I take him I can at
least think back after that the five and
that's not the worst
thing happens for the jumper the speed will come and then I'll take away the runners here next  four actually looks
kind of normal on g7 stay on it
good i have a pawn for the
jellyfish and of course the s hangs directly on its runner
echs yes of course it comes
with costumes yes okay that was okay
i thought i would have
gone and play king 7
take the film that by that the tempo
i mean namely four away
first take four first take four and then
i can start  monkeys maybe play
because it's not that easy
i'm sure if i really
should be here right next to here or if i can
first of all i can coordinate myself
next to king 7 likes it somehow better
there i'm two sad what
the heck about the g1 wants  he probably has to whether he can
also just theoretical that
looks stupid now something like that
now on the 5th
he thinks we're still a
bit a bit at a time disadvantage
what's stupid is that it looks
like he's really some again now
runner gt2 manages and the thing
exchanges that is stronger so stronger
probably ok runs the five has
to seal it somehow or is
there any tactic
stick some nonsense there or sony i
have to do it come here if two pawns
is not so bad i just
have to see that i don't
lose stuff right here somehow
i think take it now or else
i often do c5 with tempo in knight
here  7
that can't be so bad
if I can manage it or it's running slowly
she could be doing tactically well somehow
the 5
bishop c7 bishop 25 tower simply the
five is something somehow feasible here
you take away from me just could be
really hard for a long time  come on
he delivers 735 accepts that's a
shame man
87 do i have anything else then
what somehow holds this pawn near
my god how come you always play so
brutally here there isn't even a
bishop the six takes takes the way
king 7
but then I've always come to f4,
that's not so bad, so if
I give you a 7 right now, I can't
hold it well,
that works  not but i can play it
now i have chess and then the
six good that depends here i can
cover it i can only
play thoma eight doesn't speak so much against
now a king or something
if i don't
go down the drain right here  it's the position not so
bad with the 22 farmers and responsible
center
we five years school which
threatens to do strong trains what do you want to do up to 7
covers that time
couldn't have two besides think i
can't think i could
participate now is  somehow good
i doubt that so i play it like
this de 6 and lola 5 or something like
12 seconds
i even go four or so
i really only want to play the six and
runner in five to sort myself out a
bit here in the 6
too  few bases ago for the
participation
could also the 50 times first
of all the 600 infected
man
I don't know what I'm playing here now
forbidden
I can't you 15  27
the five or something threatens the chess
alright
the customers
the stuff is starting what should I do
46 can I stand it somehow here
tobias holland at f8 probably well
didn’t have time as if one can
stand it
what should the move then no  people do
c6 okay i'll go forward like
that threatens runner c6 okay
threatens to take i'll cover it briefly
here my friend is running yes he was it
still dangerous or no idea here
come on i have to do augustin g 8 or
what i'm doing right now  intercept I don't think
there's no such thing as a runner to make the 7
just played so hard
nothing to do is stopped no
idea
no idea what happened here yes
okay look at 19 games
yes the first game 1 2 lost that
was great  but i think the
games were definitely interesting
look like the first choice
so i have no idea who that was
not that difficult the second game
ok thats how we do it ever  tzt
probably just look like that because
the white game basically
I then just put something
I'm interested in how I
would have stood if I didn't do that 4
so 75 move here
the four so sprinkler 4 but then I'm
in a bad position then  then he
jumps five really stupid yes good i
always wanted i wanted to do that but
after four putts black just attack
yes i didn't play that
well i'm not in a good position what should
i do
jumper seems more sensible but
then doesn't really
work
and then I will the sgv is of course
then I haven't seen anything
yet so okay ask what
happened now if I walk
now I had actually thought after
1 then you can't play here and he
four yes that of course it's strong
threatens g3 and after that completely
apart i didn't play well that
means in other words if i
am i j  Now I'm jassim then
I have to do everything here now so that you
two are already extremely pomadig therefore just jumper
five completely overestimated
that's really no use I have to
play
that immediately I would have been good if I had
looked into it a little longer that's fine
too  much better other
comparison still nothing famous is
probably but in any case it
is better if now is exactly has
no field so comes g4 so just
let it be taken here is nothing so g4
so and now I have to move with the
knight because he again  this between
martin is that is really extremely
stupid that means for example jumps the 2
now black will probably come in
here and then play five then
i can but g3 were good
nobody knows how it is but of course
always better than the game  yes that's
really here laughs i just tried it
out a bit
now strong here wait b8 also a
good one  r listener who made
yes and now can well then
just seems to lose because of runner
he found that
and then they also found
g4s still reasonably reasonably a
fight good the jokes time easily
five or it probably really good
for  white- or would be good for white if
the non-runner three opponents
but unfortunately he works and then g3 f&e is
really broken so everything fits only
if I take now it will be beaten and
I will probably be completely
destroyed so I can't take and
if  who is taken goes just goes
the 1
and then that depends but also you
can just just ninth place
okay that was a bad game all
of me played by black not very
well so let's see here
this one here  the social walk we're
shooting so of course there's
another variant that i like to hear
but i can't really learn
the four so i ha  b then taken and
how much done
that may somehow be normal
the computer now gives the five of
course has a certain logic is that
also just stupid is also stupid
also stated directly as broke
they unpacked something like that now g5
and then  learns that is of course
extremely brutal if there I mean what’s
good
the computer just says bishop f2 and
knows wins
that somehow this can’t be possible
with team b 5 that was also clear
to me but after I once drew bishop
c6 there was  somehow
not much anymore
so it seemed to me somehow very
shaky but of course it
can be that none of that is the case
the computer here gives something like that with
about the compensation it is of course
very French art I here but
probably not bad
okay  it seems that it really
just doesn't work here
yes and now this
crazy thing came and grabbed a computer
wi  ll just take it here and says
black is better there I
didn’t think about it at all I didn’t think about it
at all
the variant is runner i4i once around
5 of course funny now it
suddenly says not so stupid that
computer we continue with lady e3 and
runner g6  of course extremely weeks ago
the position
ok so i didn't
see it at all often didn't even think about it i
expect to have the wall fixed on the on this
train that here now i
can give the source i also did it
so i don't think it's
bad now either  or so yes here that
was such a thing i took it
now i'm really not sure
you could definitely
play king 07 thun back
and 5 i was aware that this isn't
that bad but the advantage is a
bit  that there is a bit more
coordinated then somehow a
bit sorted I also have on 6
that I originally wanted to do
computer there is here  r about the same
not that the game was really
bad after i took
it but i
really have to play here now that is really difficult here
so that yes
i somehow i don’t believe it is the
winery is so computer leave it alone
pretty clear pretty much better but
that's difficult a little time and
they played it very well
thoma 18 good the appointment easier
play six and say okay then
take the stupid pawn that's
somehow of course of course not entirely
out of hand
I have of course  a lot of pawns
definitely that's very strong but that's
not so easy with 30 seconds not
now if it goes on like this tool takes
that i can hit it
and now this pawn comes today
keeps this queenside here at the moment
somewhat at a distance
and if something like that  comes, for example
, there is no check when the king moves and the
and that is of course really huge  g that
thing covers the seven and i just turn
here to run and that's
already won it has to play differently
computer bild tom b 5 or something like that
also plays a clear advantage in black
that was maybe a really
good chance after a6 here  good okay you
have 30 seconds you see the pawn
is hanging so i covered it yes 25
good i can now has could capture two
good what i didn't see that of
course stupid i
haven't improved at all typical first
think so i don't have now
shared that when I took 27
because jenny that I can play like that
I can also even that next to yes that's like that that
's not a problem at
all I have all the farmers
for example so the box enters and then
that or have lights is of course that
really good black good ok i
didn't get it thoma 71 he got there
that's still okay now the
five was possible yes i always wanted to
try here like this  sorting that out a bit
so the six and
soviet do it has three really
really possible
ok computer wants to play springer 11 8
but there we have it collects too passive
ones but maybe that's right because the
nuclear turnaround comes on h7 first then it gets
dangerous
well now here it says here it says
better now i think you can you can
city of lohr fracht was strong back
here where he was five now interesting
move well
yes you can that is very difficult
to see how these side coverage
the computer evaluates as a compensation of
course  difficult if you
only let the thing calculate for a short time that can be anything now
could also be won refers to
its somehow that's difficult to
say
king 5 ok if of course we
actually
flashed like that now, in principle, alex thinks I
sent him four and  so i
actually had the feeling i'm
honestly he is that i'm losing here
but they have that so strong and sta  rk
played now i took
that's that it's probably then
the user here somehow wants to
play computer king r five shouldn't
exactly all moved to the left
well ok brings the movements king er
56 vj 202 tommy 21 games 6 the 1 that
can't
man no one gets it in that
time and gives black a slight
advantage no one knows can do
anything and after that is probably
after that i probably put it
away to me 8222 and black is
going well
6 since i still have it
time i ticked it off too early or
what i could have played two more
25 even wins king r 45 he and
now he comes at the end and remy horny
there was still a draw possible yes i was
probably a little
too frustrated with the motif
no idea state aiming here is
really just plain flat
that you played well yes so in that
in which you i had this chance with
h60 that wa  r so and of course
we could take only after he had four in the
opening that was possible and certainly
the biggest possibility in the party
after that although I of course stand here
as in
waldmeister note now here plays the
move in the computer is of course
also very important  strong yes and I
50 I also had that I
had even seen a bit far
with this idea I did
n't really see it either because I'm
supposed
to do it so I just got this from 906
it's stupid but of course also  yes, the
really lack of knowledge of the variant
would that a board should solve it
is not that easy because the five is
now not for me too of
course it somehow belongs to the black
program the move but
really honestly many developed so
it is not so straight  just the fact that
you just shake the war out of the sleeve
I think is of course much
stronger that's clear
from corpses that was a bang  kpunkt here
i could really i40 here it of
course is still super
confusing the position
and then i got this position
we get with the quality and it is
also really okay
that was really that was the good
possibility and here now cross-country skier
has two is of course  difficult we
are really down down and participation
as i always say you can of
course not really
calculate everything through and whatever else
yes but here in the 2 i lost mine
i wanted to coordinate
the position first now also
normally not that wrong  if you
just have quality so somehow springer
runner and plus pawns that you
try to create fixed bases
and at the moment he runs on the six he
has no and of course villages
i5 and the six but there is the
mood here is direct I I
should  just take
I really didn't clench at all
that his that I to be  iplay
here that that hasn’t been done either yes
I can can’t count that here locally private
not at all
once you’ve got that far then you can see that
fairly quickly that this doesn’t
happen that much
here comes and I should just blog the eleven
lines  then happen I have
four connected passed pawns here
that's quite a bit yes but
I think it's an exciting match and
as I said we both commented
so the whole thing is then also not available to the
other channel either then
linking will be a lot of fun  while
watching hear that other videos and
that will still give my
revenge all right sda